N
>>JI
HAD THIS IS CNN OVERDOSES
C
WHAT IS THE PUBLIC HERE? WHER'
THROH IO
A RELATIVELY  OF LISTENERS.
IT MUCHIER. IN
12F
BROADCAST DEFYTH
PLATFORM FOR LIVE O. THE COMPAN
AUDIFEIN DIFFERENTIE POLICE, FI
MARADIO
COMMUNICATIONS. BROATER FEEDS E
ACCESS THROUGH ITS WEBSITE AND
SMARTPHONE APPS, REACHING 50 TO
BL,000 LISTENERS ON A TYG ULTILY
TRANSPARENCY TO WHAT'S GOING
YARDS. BUT
IS THERE A CITIES INCLUDING DEN
BALTIMORE, CHICAGO, NEW YORK,
OUX FALLARE NOW EN
COBLIC RADIO CHANNELS DUE
ABTH
WOICWIDER AUDIENCEICIZING NAMEAI
ENCRYPTINGADFROM THAT WOULD MEA
THAUTHORIZED EMERGENCY
PROFESSIONALS COULD ACION RGENT
MATTER IN REAL TIME. WE FOUND
SEVERAL PLE,
THIS AN ELDERLMA
SC
BLTO  70 YEAR-OLD HAT
ARGUE THAT POLICE SCANNERS HELP
THE PUBLDEINDIVIDUS MIGHT BE A O
LE MENRLECTS
THINK HE'S WALKING WITHIC
OR CANE IS GOIBE IN FRONT
OF THE STORE WHERE I'VE LEFT
FEELING
>> BUT AT WHAT POINT DOES A
RADIO CHANNEL THAT'S MEANT TO
UPHOLD PUBLIC SAFETY INFRINGE
ON THE PRIVATE DETAILS OF  SAY,
SUICIDE THOUGHTS
>> ON HER ARCOID
WI B
PERSONAL DETAILSAU
NE WHO NEEDS
EFDS BLANOUNDERINING ME NOW IS
ADIONDSAY. THANK YOU FOR BEING
CARL HALL, WONDERFUL GUY,
WMBER AS HAVI
BUT NOS HAVE ACCESS, INCLUDING
WEBSITHA  USLY TNTAMG CHANGED T
THATT LISTENING INTO OUR
CAIC SAFET
JT
STREG SERVICES. SO THAT'S
REALLY WHAT'S CHANGED IN THE
HOOSE AT LISTENED TO
POLICE SCANNERDAY.  MAKE IT CLE
TEAM AND BY THE WAY,ESEL OF IONW
T GR T N, 'S
OFF-TSAS THI
D
RMATION, SUCH AS CIES HIGHLY
SWATND
ORTHNICATESET FOR TIONR
THE GENERAL RULE BUTENE
PUBLICETAGENCIESEAVE  INITOR BEE
IS A BENEFIT TO THAT TO THPUBLI
OPERIOS. E
LATE JAKE
BELIEVES THAT, AS SUHISILIKE THC
O PROVIDE SOMEOVER
YO
HE PRINSNDS
THAT I LAID OUT IN
AMES AND  AGENCI TSURE. IT'S DEY
ADDRESSES AND SPECIFIC PION OVEO
T BLIC TO BE ATO
HE THAINHE
PRIVACY CONCERNS, THERE
CERTAINLY CERTAINLY.
ONUTONDO YOU THIOO FAR? I RATTLS
DI  C SAFETY AGENCIES HAVE TEC'D
TOBROADCAST
GENERAL PUBLHRREND OF EST CITIET
TESTE
IC BALTIMORE, WHO JUST  ENCRYPT
DAY-TO-DAY COMMUNICATIONS.
PROVIDED DELAYFE
THEY SEE THE BENEFIT OFUNITY HE
DAY-TO-DAY OPERATIOF THEIRHE ST
ABOUT THIS SUBJECT ATAHIHE
GREATEST CONCERN THAT I HAD IS
THAT IT MIGHT
>> HESITANCY ON THE PART OF
SOMEBODY WHO NEEDS HELP BECAUSE
MAYBE IT'S AN EMBARRASSING
PREDICAMENT OR MAYBE THEY WORR'T
'T WANT
SOMEBODY NOT TO DIA'S IN  IFREM
COVERING A AUT SOMEBODY A SERVI
THE GEL PUBLIC TO KEEP THEMARE,
WHAT'S GOIN IN THEICAIEIMES
DU MDRPELENE INTO WHAT TO KNOWH
BL, AGENCI AAY AGENCIES, THEY
THEY THEY KNOW THAT